these will all be easier we just think
of an example okay so I am just starting
to get out okay here we go
you know you're a teacher boom when the
biggest money in your wallet is if you
said coin okay if we've got a coin
you've got a coin okay and we flip it
twice that's what we're gonna think
about this okay coin okay so that's the
situation that we've got right now
you've learned over the past few years
what well now there are lots of
different ways to illustrate this okay
and to say well I can visualize what's
happening here apart from actually just
flipping a coin okay now in this case
you've got three options you've got
three options
okay and they go sort of in order of
complexity okay
so the first way is just to list out
what are all the possibilities of things
that can happen what's the sample space
okay that's the phrase that we usually
use right in this case it works because
if you flip a fair coin twice there are
four and only four possible outcomes and
you can name them for me what are the
footballs without that's what's one of
them you get the two heads okay a head
and then a head again right what's
another alternative you get two tails
right good to a missing what are y'all
toes head tail head first and in tail
and then tail head okay done there you
go so now your sample space now you're
missing out and now any question I
thought you you can just look at the
alternatives there and say look there
they are now alternatively you could do
a dot diagram for this okay you could do
a dot diagram so how would a dot diagram
look like morning for a scenario like
this we're gonna have two axes right so
it looks something like
right now what do the what do the axes
represent hmm you gotta have some
options this way and some options this
way
now in some senses it's not that
important here you know it's the same
sample space for the first coin toss as
for the second okay
but they might not be the same so what
we do is we distinguish one of them's
gonna be the first plus and one's gonna
be the second one
right so for your first one you either
get a head or a tail and then for your
second one
you either get a head or a tail okay and
now as the name implies is dot diagram
you've got one two three four
alternatives and of course you could
fill them out you could say well that's
head head that's this is the top right
that's tail head that's head tail that's
tail tail you've got the same set about
outcomes there okay
when might this might be a better
alternative than just listening about
probably when you've just got more
options more options however you're
still limited at least with this you
know we've only got two dimensions on
our page so you're kind of limited to
having fit twice if I flip it three
times you're already out of the running
okay if I did flip it three times how
can I represent it okay what's our third
option list dot diagram or you could do
a tree right you could do a tree that
branches off like that okay so now again
it's pretty simple right you've got to
start with two or two news head and tail
right and then after each of those you
either get a head or a tail or a head or
a tail and that's if you want to get
into the terminology okay that's a tree
diagram to make it a probability tree
diagram what would I have to add on
today what's missing yeah that's right
the waiting's for each of the branches
okay now you can kind of get away with a
heat because all of the branches are
gonna have the same waiting no problems
okay but of course you know if I didn't
make a fair coin if I made an AM and
you know casino coins okay tails is more
like it sound like that right you're
going to get different probabilities on
each of these branches but for this
scenario we'll just put on aha
okay so now that we have our ways of
representing these let's think about the
product rule and how it worked
okay it's easiest to illustrate when you
look at the tree diagram suppose I said
to you what's the probability of getting
two heads in a row
simple question right how do we compute
it off this diagram like how do we
compute I don't the answer I know what
the answer is but how do you actually
get the answer okay as the name suggests
the products were all not to be confused
with the product rule calculus right if
you've got these two events right and
they are happening together right
there's a hand and the other here right
I want them at the same time then I
multiply them 1/2 times 1/2 and that's
the 1/4 that you expected
okay of course you can verify that by
going back to the beginning our list and
saying it cuz it's fair all of these are
equally likely and there are four of
them so it must be a quota okay now
that's the product rule when you've got
simultaneous events I might even write
that
the ProTools for simultaneous it is or
events that occur together